okay I'm ready Yeah right let's do it
okay take take like five for me jeez I
haven't been able to get a single
episode
hi everybody whatever okay okay oh
that's what I do wanna see a pretty girl
across the street we know JP's dating
strategy don't you judge my dating I use
that dude which which yeah which are you
good
please not the Wraiths the other ding
donged uh-huh well maybe he's just
saving his dings can't be unleashing all
the dong he's a little bigger thingy
whoa oh they're a JP you got this no I
don't I'm gonna die he's gonna find me
and it's gonna be yogurt
we're gonna run to nowhere so in this
house you still in this house wait don't
wait no come on come on wait no what are
you doing what are you doing wait are
you being like that Wade don't do things
wait don't do things we don't don't
don't be things don't do things wait
don't you do anything right back at me
why did that happen
I know to the walls you're gonna watch
me aren't you I don't think I don't
think that I don't think anything that
you are so nice
I don't think anything that you are is
the bigger man Wade okay so guys new
strategy now that what are you what are
you talking about
go team go oh crap a run for us please
do something really extracting wait
don't break my arm it looks so weird
with you guys just rubbing all over my
back it's like their favor
they rubbed me real good they rubbed me
raw well that doesn't sound good
game so Derek dear I'm an earth then do
it everybody it's very fair are you a
style
thank you for your fair place I might
win nothing everything's fine seaweed
yeah Wade I believe in you you're a
great killer you're gonna do great
things in life I'm great and I love you
alright I'm running to the fight
somebody
alright somebody come rub me there's a
lot of rubbin going on why aren't I
part of this leave me alone
I'm sorry do you live no no no your
teammates okay that's a bit extreme
don't die for your demon just get
seriously injured yeah that's preferable
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you guys are so good at the engines
and I'm like our generators and I'm like
awful yeah and I'm gonna hide just hush
get better at it please I think I'm
about to die I think death ain't gonna
approach me no I mean I'm just saying in
general wait you're being you're being
totally unfair you need to work out your
aggression and more healthy outlets yeah
why don't we talk about it you know yoga
Pilates you know maybe some summer some
bro aromatherapy that'd be nice I've got
a Mary Kay
[Laughter]
oh ouch Gibble's I was wondering if that
was a bad idea
wait I'm sorry we can't stop rubbing
stopping nobody's rubbed me yet I'm
still open JP where are you at I'll rub
you this is supposed to be a love story
love rub story that's a different story
wave doesn't sound good experience
wait I'm never gonna get wait wait no
somebody help you I didn't know that was
a thing I thought I was done for
I see thank you Hey now you can rub you
now yeah wait generator you're gonna get
away from me I'm just chimp up you never
know if somebody you got to take the
time to run
[Music]
that was a thing what I'm gonna I'm
gonna predict something I'm I'm a
particular getaway Marco no no hello
shut up
I see him he's in the cornfield no he's
not it looks stupid or maybe he is not
under percent sure about anything
anymore a pallet reporting live from
Wade headquarters he's thing donging is
he okay okay okay okay
wait no wait did someone get this end
okay nevermind forget forget everything
I was wrong hello you can do it open one
of the exits open one of them
somebody [ __ ]
I got you everybody behind I love the
wood open wait that's personal
wait that felt personal Wade you're
stupid stop it you're stupid
[Music]
don't mind me hold my intestines in no
no best time for rub time yeah Wade you
may have made a horrible error what
we're very scared Wade you're a good
monster
[Music]
bring boys is gonna what the [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]